get started everybody cool so they just
was there dinner or we just
see all night long is that what's going
on there were snacks and now we're gonna
talk some more all right well I'll try
to keep you won't take too much out of
your dinner time and John skeet and I
are going to Aladdin afterwards so I
have a reason to get out of here fast
thank you okay cool um is this being
filmed do we know oh that's too bad
you'd be more frank if the camera you
know just fell over accidentally and
suddenly recording didn't happen yeah no
one will know cool all right well I'll
try to be as Frank as I can because I
try to keep it real I want to talk about
what an open-source Microsoft framework
looks like about what we've done and
what we're doing in my and again if I
get anything wrong cuz Damien's not in
the country anymore it's entirely my
fault if I get any of the messaging
wrong or the technical stuff wrong Jon's
keats taking notes about what I get
wrong and he's actually gonna slack that
over to Damien and say well you know
Hanson was close but he got this part
wrong a lot of this stuff's my opinion
and it is all a little bit
oversimplified but I want to give you
some context about how we should think
about asp.net core and in.net core um
who is doing dotnet core right now for
money
alright cool and did you do it
like through the various and sundry
release candidates that we've had yeah
it's pretty excited about that
no not really feeling it all right let
me explain a little bit of stuff about
that in my in my terms and the best of
my ability
so did anyone start it when it was
asp.net 5 a couple people any people
here who know nothing about asp.net core
they just know that it's a thing and
it's coming and they came here to learn
about it alright cool and the rest of
you are just too tired to raise your
hands and that's fine
okay so let's talk let's just talk let's
do real talk right now we came up with
this thing called asp.net 5 it seemed
like a really good idea because 5 is
greater than 4.6 that's really why we
called it that and but we have to think
about the context and this is the kind
of stuff that doesn't fit in a tweet and
I say this because I feel
that people have a tendency to take
multiple years work by multiple dozens
of people and condense it into a mean
tweet and or sub tweet and you forget
that things are complicated life is
complicated organizations are
complicated technical decisions are
complicated and your sub tweet is not
appreciated
notice how I'm actually subtweeting you
right now you're like is he talking
about me I probably am but you'll never
know because it is a sub tweet from
stage um seriously though people say
like oh it sucks you know dotnet core
they were idiots what the hell of you
things happen organizations happen let's
talk about what happened what does the
org look like you may or may not know
these things you know that there are
three Scots between me and Satya and
we're all just interchangeable Scots
Scott hunter whose name isn't even Scott
it's Carl owns asp.net he owned asp.net
and who did he work for he worked for
Scott Guthrie who worked in Azure okay
that makes sense right the web framework
works runs under the you know the web
thing at Microsoft and then that we went
off and we said yeah it's gonna be
awesome we're gonna make asp.net five
where is dotnet then well they're over
in dev div with soma remember soma and
people under there who we don't know who
do visual studio because they're there
they don't come out in the light and
then we've got his code then we got
Richard Lander and the folks that are
doing dotnet and I'm putting one name by
that but there's lots of cool people
that you've all heard about but what's
interesting about this is we have two
different divisions and we've got the
web framework over there so in this org
chart we have a situation where asp.net
is a customer of dotnet right we are
kind of upstream or downstream but we
are you know in a vector away from net
so organizationally that's interest
interesting dotnet gets finished and it
gets thrown over and then asp.net sits
on top of it and we go and we write
stuff okay so we go and we make asp.net
five and it's gonna be awesome and we do
stuff like this
you know what I mean
and it's like dnl pcz STR string its
reusing polish notation for that one
that's an old C++ joke no one gets so we
make those utilities but the significant
aspect of this was if you remember in
asp.net when you got it early on
you'd say file new project and there was
an asp.net 5 console app John skeet goes
mm-hmm he did you didn't go like that it
was kind of a grover slash Yoda kind of
a mmm and then that was weird right and
that was where you would have a console
app and you type you know DNX or
whatever to run the thing instead of foo
dot exe there was a different host and
then that then begat as these things to
a class library which was the asp.net 5
class library which then kind of virally
starts to become a problem but it's not
a problem if this org holds it makes
total sense because we weren't making
dotnet core we were making asp.net 5 and
it made sense and it would run
cross-platform ago to work on azor and
everything was great so then two things
happened that changed that changed
things one of them you know about and
one of them you may not know about what
are the two things that happen massive
earth-shattering stuff we bought xamarin
I found out about xamarin being bought
when I read it on TechCrunch because
that's how M&A works that's how you know
mergers and acquisitions work they don't
tell anyone because if it gets out then
it won't happen I also found out that we
were buying LinkedIn when Scott Guthrie
added me on LinkedIn
true story and I went mm-hmm
I wonder if he's looking for a gig
what's going on do you need a
recommendation Scott goo I'll recommend
you it's alright you can use my network
I'm excited to add you to my
professional network at LinkedIn Scott
and then like 20 minutes later so then I
imagined in my mind this probably is not
how it happened I imagine like Satya and
the LinkedIn guy and Guthrie like
teaching Guthrie to sign up for LinkedIn
and they're holding his hand as he you
know one finger cuz that's how bosses
type and he signs up oh I'm on the
Facebook now who should I add as my
friend
oh it's Hanselman is outdated profile
picture let's go ahead and and we'll
pick that guy and then I'm at home like
you know with Cheetos and Netflix and
hookup three once you've been my friend
in LinkedIn so so that happened Sam
uhrin that you knew about that then what
else happened that was also massive an
earth-shattering reorge
reorge Game of Thrones net
red wedding it was awful sohma's retired
he's gone
and then now julia loosen is in charge
over there and then we've got John
Montgomery who's lovely John Mantua
column and then there was like an arm
wrestling match and they picked they
needed to have Ascot he's the Scot that
one and what they did is they said where
does asp.net go because now we've got
mono and dotnet and this weird asp.net
five thing and it's long so where's it
gonna go
asp.net really belongs over here so then
they fight and it's like a Pokemon thing
and rock-paper-scissors so now Scott
hunter runs asp.net and dotnet all up so
Scott hunter becomes the second Scott
he's a lesser Scott and then Richard
Lana ResNet and then I work under Scott
hunter doing outreach and community and
a sure is still Scott got three but that
he becomes seen he's seeing E right and
I don't know see is I thought it was
cloud and an enterprise but then someone
else did he owns Windows server so then
it was server and enterprise with like
the little unlock or whatever the little
Frenchie thing but it's not it's cloud
and enterprise and then so then we're
all we all serve at the pleasure of the
goo we kiss the ring in genuflect when
we see them but now the dotnet starts
coming together both organizationally
and with these companies things have to
change
do you know how many different project
types there are with dotnet it's like
nineteen like legit like you start
thinking about unity and xamarin and all
these different things and then then the
concept of an asp.net 5 class library
it's a little confusing and you have to
ask yourself well who's wagging the dog
here right is asp.net wagging net so
what we did is we slammed everyone
together and we had all the architects
figure it out but the mistake was that
when we released it we had this thing
called RC one
and it was released candidates are
supposed to be released candidates they
are a candidate for release but then the
world exploded and what was a released
candidate was no longer a release
candidate totally understandable funnily
enough I don't think that's a word that
doesn't fit into a tweet what I just
explained right life happens
organizations happen mergers happen
reorge happen but the result is you all
continue to whine about how it wasn't a
release candidate I get it
it's okay yes we know it was not a
release candidate but the runtime is
solid we've worked out a lot of really
interesting problems and the result is
we're going to come out on the other
side of this with a dotnet that can
compete who are we competing with when I
go out and teach young people that's the
set of all people who are not you all
when I teach them programming what do we
do hey kids we're gonna learn visual
studio.net it's gonna be great first
we're gonna download Visual Studio and
then tomorrow we're gonna install update
three that's not cool right so what are
the kids doing
what are the kids doing they're going
apt install Python go Ruby Java
well maybe not PHP Python right I don't
have to spell Python they're installing
everything except dotnet cuz zero to ten
is really easy in those things and I
said this two years ago and I'll say it
now apt have to get your apt install.net
dotnet new donut run that's the goal
right when the kids out there today
make application foo they go Ruby foo
Python foo they need to go dotnet foo
and then C sharp or F sharp or VB needs
to work everywhere you need to feel
great about it and it needs to be more
fun than Java it needs to be as fast and
as exciting as go it needs to have
native support so it'll make things like
go native executables and the
maybe a great web framework like node
and we need to compete on a level
playing field with open source will win
or we won't based on it not sucking that
is the goal so we went and we bought
this awesome domain dotnet of course I'm
giving you like the mysterious secret
internal marketing strategy how are we
gonna win we're gonna buy a domain
dotnet can it just be dotnet no it's not
how domains work are you sure can't
people just type dotnet and it'll be up
no it's no that's sir that's not how it
works your manager stop talking and of
course we just redirect it to Microsoft
coms last net I'm working on that these
things take time within another reorg or
two this will probably be slash dotnet
so regardless dotnet it's an awesome I
worked very hard on that and you can go
up here and you can say Donald download
dot net core and you get this lovely
thing with these six different flavors
of Linux which is nice and docker and
Mac and Windows and you can also go here
which is cool right and use Rosland and
then do that and you can actually click
on the full tutorial here which is
lovely we're gonna probably open source
all this and explain how the sandbox
works and you can go in here and say
what experience you have and will judge
you if you push Java and then every
single one of these samples has a lovely
do the work here so I could actually
teach probably four to six hours of a
c-sharp class without even downloading
the thing that's the level of which
we're trying to do we want to get these
in code camps and vocational schools and
colleges right we're going full-on I've
got someone working for me full-time
right now trying to get us into
vocational schools and stuff like that
okay
is this useful context wouldn't it be
great if it fit in a tweet would it be
great if Google+ actually was a thing
now that would not be great so here's
where things go to hell - heck sorry my
son is right there hello
here's where things go to heck this is
just you know versioning versioning
stuff so dotnet framework 4.6 is out by
the way four point six two is out very
exciting you know we got rid of in four
point six point two max path yeah 2016
y'all now you can have long filenames
congratulations
there's always something about filenames
that's messing us up in the dotnet world
do you know what the code name was for
dotnet before we called it dotnet it was
based on comm right not com+
comm 3 I love this there's a room full
of people I just told an obscure
historical dotnet joke and only John
Skeet got it
why can't you name dotnet comm 3 because
you can't have a file called comm 3
because it's a comport there's already
one old people joke yes the old people
are like haha the young people like I
have no idea what he's talking about how
old are we
we're so old that when we make our
project Jason's we go copy con we type
him out like that oh wow I've already
got one in my desktop never used copy
con copy confu dot txt ABC control Z or
Zed yeah
today that's how we make files copy from
console you can't have a file called
comm 3 because it's the comport so
that's why we didn't name it comm 3
though aren't you happy that we named it
dotnet because it's totally fine to have
a folder with the dot in the front of it
also a joke that no one gets that's ok
for six runs on four 6s Ben two four six
has web forms it has MVC and Web API and
work continues as you can see with
asp.net 4.6 point to lots of great new
stuff okay you take a look at the blog
post there's a lot of good stuff
asp.net core 1.0 this is the message I
need to get to the bosses this is the
one weirdness about all of this core one
runs on dotnet framework which runs on
Windows and it runs just fine I've got
all these customers that are like well I
don't really know if I need the
cross-platform stuff I'm not really
ready to go to dotnet core we do
everything in Windows everything's fine
what do I use usually asp.net core one
it works just fine it runs on Windows
it's released here's where it gets
confusing it's because asp.net core
straddles
the full framework and the core
framework people don't know people don't
get they don't register that this is a
new asp.net that has been brought down
to its core it's a rewrite at its core
but it can run on either the full
framework just fine and do all the great
full framework stuff that needs to do or
it can run a dotnet core people then say
oh Microsoft you're stupid you always
say naming is hard it's not hard just
call it fancy web and we'll all just
come along you just give it a new name
right don't call it asp.net ASP Nets got
baggage it's also got 15 years of
enterprise customers and multiple tens
of millions of people and websites that
use it just fine and if we made a thing
called fancy web or web matrix even then
I'm sure that people would all come
along and use that product wouldn't they
it doesn't work that way
when you buy it when you have a good
name for a product and you don't have
the ability to call it go you know or
some two letter noun really cool that
they could do that though
amazed that they could actually name the
thing go uh you got to call it don't
like that so cor really made sense it
was brought down to its core okay so
remember this a it's been in that core
1.0 straddles those things okay now this
was the the goal of this right to be
totally modular to give a faster
development cycle that means you want to
be able to have the benefits of static
typing the benefits of a fast CLR but
the ability to hit f5 and just have that
thing work we want to be able to choose
your editors and tools what's funny
about this is it looks like these are
all the exact opposite of what a
Microsoft web framework would do like
you could probably go through this and
say Microsoft of old would do exactly
none of these things we would make it
deliberately slow we would make it so
when you hit ctrl shift B you have to go
to lunch and you only can use Visual
Studio but it is a totally new Death
Star it is literally like we're all just
running around with stormtrooper helmets
on just trying not to blow up Alderaan
again we have this great Death Star
available to us and we don't know what
we're doing we're just pushing buttons
but I can tell you this we may be on the
Death Star
we're not evil because Microsoft is not
organized enough to be as evil as you
think that we are does that make sense
this is a fact all right now one of the
things that's causing us a lot of
problems is that again people don't know
that core one runs on 4.6 but they also
don't know what's supported and what's
not and when they should start because
people watch the asp.net community stand
up who watches that every Tuesday right
content free I don't know why you watch
it they watch the stand up and they
watch Twitter and they see all of this
drama happening day by day and it feels
like a soap opera and it stresses them
out because things are happening because
you you asked to see what was going on
in the kitchen and now you're not happy
when you see how the sausage gets made
right it's just not pretty you would
never eat sausage if you saw what it
looked like when you make sausage so I
tell people just chill out give it a
couple of months and then come back and
you
see progress getting made so Damien came
up with this amazing Australian way of
looking at how you should think about
asp.net and he did it in terms of meat
he says if you want it well done which
frankly is a waste of meat you get
Visual Studio you get nougat you won't
get salmonella
it'll be textualist but it'll work and
you won't die medium well that's when
you start getting into see TPS and
released betas right medium or medium
rare tastes better but you have to put
up with the potential for you know I
don't know death things go wrong you
have to understand that you did skewed
it order the food that way that's why
they have that little warning on the
menu right now did you know I guess you
didn't know cuz you're all our
Australian that there's a thing that's
rarer than rare blue I just smacked the
cow in the butt and send them out like
it's just like how do you want that cook
sir so a good doctor could bring him
back I want to look my cow in the eye
well you asked for it so we will give
you the ability to really you know cook
dotnet completely blue this is where
again from a classic perspective people
get confused they buy Enterprise Visual
Studio and then they think that they
have to do things that way I will talk
to enterprise customers well I bought
Visual Studio I paid lots of money for
we have an enterprise support contract
for you and now I have to build dotnet
from source what's going on they'll ask
questions like that they don't
understand that there is a continuum and
we even are having trouble explaining it
to you all because you're the advanced
hacker types the difference between
supported allowed and might be possible
right so can I run dotnet core on a
Raspberry Pi that's a complicated
question can you should you ought you
should I allow you to would you want to
you know those are all the kinds of
questions we want to enable a hacker
culture around net but we also don't
to find out that someone just went and
deployed 10,000 raspberry pies without
really understanding what was going on
and then now they want support for it we
don't currently have support for gotten
on a raspberry pie but it's totally
possible
that makes sense so we need to make that
really clear to folks and we're trying
to figure out how to do that so if you
have suggestions or thoughts about how
to foster hacker culture but let people
know that as soon as you're off of
medium-well or off of a go live license
if you in fact I have Salmonella you
don't get to get mad at us that makes
sense so that's one of the things that
we're thinking about around dotnet and
dotnet core and asp.net core the other
thing that we're thinking about is for
the first time we're gonna start going
out and talking about benchmarks so
we're gonna get in the tech empower
benchmarks have you seen the tech
empower benchmarks tech empower has
these cool benchmarks and we're gonna
get in there tech and power benchmarks
they do like different rounds round 12
is the current round right now from
February and long tail is long so I will
point out that if you look at these
things this is like the hello world
plaintext benchmark and the long tail is
quite long so it's like stuff I've never
heard of does many millions of requests
a second then you get to Neddie which
i've heard of and then you go looking
for like go and there's go at a million
which is cool and then you look for node
and there's node and see how long tail
just got long down here like this and
then it's just like everybody else right
there's so much random stuff I think
that these are like these are either
docker container names where they just
been auto-generated twisted Klein
apparently is doing well with thin grape
coming up just behind it
I have no these are real things though
but here's the thing I don't know what's
wrong with this person here cherry pie
so we will have CTOs and folks that will
look at this benchmark and they'll say
well you suck because you're at this
level right but they don't understand
that we are racing you know Formula one
cars against motorcycles against
minivans
right and if you go into like webforms
and you make a hello world in a web form
and then try to hit it a million times
that's a minivan and that's not what it
was meant to do it was meant to do
enterprise text boxes over data
applications with an artificial event
management system that made stateless
HTTP not stateless that takes a lot of
work and if all you're trying to do is
say hello world that's stupid
you're never gonna win with the Tesla
going up against a minivan but then they
will do that anyway and they'll go that
sucks so what we try to do with dotnet
core was make things modular enough that
you could do those kinds of comparisons
with web forms which was made in 20 mm
mm 1 2002 you got everything and you
removed stuff with dotnet core you get
nothing you don't even get an error
message page you don't even get the
yellow screen of death you don't get
static file handling and you have to add
everything individually there were all
these articles that were written back in
the day about how to harden asp.net and
now we've inverted it and we include
nothing by default and if you added
something and screwed up that's your
fault so we're gonna make it so you can
go and do plain text benchmarks and we
very much believe if you go to github
slash asp net slash benchmarks then
we're going to get into the millions of
requests a second well I'm github open
up some more tabs of github there we go
seriously it still says asp.net 5 do I
have access what what I don't know if I
can do a pull request for the thingy
where's the set I don't have settings I
don't have power do I
this is I like to do bugs that are like
live on stage
I'm pretty sure they don't need the link
I think that they'll figure that out
I've been working really hard for a half
an hour and you applauded for that
that's that's all good I'm all right
with that at least I got some kind of
applaud even though even your pity
applause that's fine
so Kestrel can do with libuv and c-sharp
upwards of two million requests a second
using the Tekken power benchmarks and
we're seeing with things like Windows
registered i/o almost 6 million we're
not really sure where we're gonna get
but in our internal tests we are seeing
numbers in order you know around 5
million requests against no doing around
600,000 and that's that's cool and this
isn't this is going to be us being
public and making statements and
hopefully it will usher in some really
cool discussions and some really cool
optimizations where we raise the water
level for everybody everyone gets faster
historically Microsoft hasn't really
done that too much now this is a BS
marketing slide that they have make me
put in but that is a really cool number
right there 18,000 people outside
Microsoft contributing to repositories
that's cool
so this is what dotnet looked like in
2015 when we took the github issues and
commits and pull requests and said who
cares and where are those people
and here's dotnet in 2016 and if we
lower our minimum bar about what a
contribution is to small changes it
looks like this so you've got tens of
thousands of people now working on net
and doing cool stuff with it and in fact
the core FX the core part of net is
about 40% external contributions right
now which is pretty sweet makes sense so
let me show you some of the stuff that
makes
me happy about dotnet and again if
you've already seen it and this bores
you I apologize ahead of time I always
make a folder like that that way I'll
know to delete it later
cuz you don't want that kind of stuff on
your desktop alright yeah it spins up
your crap is that a bad word here is
that like worse than usually bad I can
never tell what's a bad word in
Australia anything you say could
potentially be a bad word so if I say
dotnet - - version I tell right now it's
telling me this preview three zero zero
three one eight oh okay
where is dotnet today friends down here
right and there's a couple of
interesting things about where dotnet is
it's in the windows folder so right off
the bat it's windows and remember how
did you get dotnet before right there's
two ways to get dotnet upgrade windows
or really really want to get the latest
version of paint.net right which would
then make you go and get whatever the
way that says how it is right when
non-technical parent calls when dad
calls and he's like I really want this
paint program and they want me to
download something called dotnet I'll
screw it I'll just upgrade your windows
in the old days though we used to ask
ourselves what version of the framework
do we have on those machines and less
and less do we have to think about that
because everyone has dotnet now since
Windows 7 right but ultimately though
it's it's in Windows Microsoft net and
we are afraid of it we don't have to be
afraid of it but we are and it sucks
that we're afraid of it because what
happens is and I see this again and
again is that someone works on on
application let's say that you're
working on four point five window at
four point five it's an expense
reporting app and it works great and you
deploy it to a server at work okay and
then let's say that she is doing four
point six point two writing another app
on her own machine and now she wants to
put her app on the same server as your
app and you say I don't think so because
you are irrationally afraid of upgrading
the machine because it's going to be 300
Meg
it's gonna be a reboot there's gonna be
downtime and you are afraid that four
point six point two will break your 4.5
app you don't feel like testing it you
can't do side by side time passes and
then in the in some future world we're
on a soup another version of.net you're
the equivalent of dotnet to she's quit
and gone to node because you won't let
her be great and do cool stuff with link
in c-sharp seven right and you're like I
don't know twos good enough for me and
that continues right people say well I'm
not really quite sure I don't want to
upgrade till it's baked and then the
next thing you know two versions of.net
goes away the cool young people doing
cool stuff have left for another
framework and we are afraid of dotnet it
is a highly compatible upgrade until it
isn't right and so that one story or
that one bit of anecdote that you hear
that someone had trouble and it broke
their application and then you're afraid
of it we need to be in a situation where
we're not afraid of dotnet and that you
can have not only your own private
version of.net but you can be guaranteed
that anything that anyone else does on
that machine won't break it but even
more what if she didn't just have her
own version of dotnet she wanted to have
a custom forked version of Roslyn and
she has past versions of asp.net and she
did added her own features the c-sharp
she should be able to do that and it
should be totally okay and that's where
we get into that blurry line about
supported versus allowed versus that's
totally awesome that you did that
there's a really great application that
Frank Krueger just came out called
continuous and continue to it's at
continuous dot codes I thought it was
awesome that we took over a top-level
domain he actually has continuous dot
codes as his website it's Visual Studio
for your iPad this is a real thing and
he did it by forking Roslyn the casis
sharp compiler and getting it to run on
an iPad he wrote the whole thing in F
sharp and you can literally write C
sharp and get Intel isense
on a frickin iPad yeah it's insane I'm
telling you it's a real thing and he did
that because of things like being able
to fork Roslyn so we want to enable that
ability but we can't do that when dotnet
ships
with windows so where is dotnet now we
go back here and we type in where net
and I like I like showing young people
giving young people at your work that
like don't know about like how great
daus is they love PowerShell or whatever
tell them about things like wear you
know little features like that or maybe
just in the middle of showing them stuff
just throw in like a little pop D a
little push D just to make them kind of
keep keep them wondering and then just
lightly press f7 and then hit escape
really quick so that they're like what
is that Windows 10 that is Windows 10 it
is also das 4 and it's awesome yes
here's the f7 so I'm gonna say we're net
and where is it right it's right there
it's not in Windows it's not even
versioned it's sitting there let's go
and type dotnet - - version we see it's
three one eight oh I'm gonna go back
over to see Program Files dotnet go to
SDK and look there's the the tooling the
SDK we did something weird where we
wanted to release net the runtime was
good it was solid it is released it is
1.0 but the tooling the sdk was holding
us back
it's really easy to make a great runtime
if there's no UI on top of it but as
soon as you need a property dialog box
or something with text boxes over data
and you need to internationalize it and
localize it into 20 different languages
then you find the runtime team sitting
around waiting for someone to make a
dialog box on top of project Jason so we
at Microsoft split that dotnet core is
released it is supported you call
support they will support you but the
tooling remains in a preview beta stage
okay I'm running some daily builds that
I went and downloaded if I just delete
those
okay and then go dotnet - des version
I've got that version and if I go
where's my stuff
there's minecraft and restore that stuff
and run it again I've got that so I just
uninstalled and install.net or install
them uninstalled done that then I say
dotnet new and I've got project Jason
talk about that in a second and I've got
program dots yes I'm going to open up
notepad - which is one better than
notepad and I'm gonna go like this and
I'm gonna add console dot read line okay
I'm gonna say dotnet restore can't do it
cuz y'all are watching
that's like NPM install or gems or
whatever and now I'm running that out
but I did a console dot readline so it
would pause right there and hold okay so
then I'm going to right click and hit
task manager and I'm gonna go looking
for dotnet and it's there twice and task
manager sucks so we'll close it I will
go into process explorer where the real
work is done and I will run it as admin
and I will look around for net it's just
right there
and there's two of them that first one
is the version non-specific one right
that's the one that thinks about which
one to run makes sense you should see
the wheels are going now so here dotnet
- - version is preview three right okay
I'm gonna hit start dot another thing to
show the young people type in source and
I'm gonna go into source put in
something else and then I'm gonna copy
all of this stuff in there so now I've
got a solution II kind of a thing going
on here right
so then here in that root folder I'm
going to go back to and by the way you
should always blog because then you can
Google yourself later and I'm gonna go
and find cuz I knew I wrote about this
once
bla bla bla bla bla seriously if you
will just blog twice a week for 15 years
then you will have a really great bunch
of stuff copy Khan global Jason control
V control Z dotnet - test version what
just happened
other than the control Z kind of thing
was awesome because can copy Connors
path this is my version of Emacs right
because whenever I watch Emacs people
doing that whole thing because I have a
version of Emacs running at home that I
don't know how to close and they're so
condescending they're like oh yes you
know ctrl shift alt K and then you do a
little dance and then you know it swaps
the two lines I don't know how to do any
of that stuff but I can copy Khan like a
so I just made a global Jason and I said
I'm gonna pin the SDK version to a
specific version the one that was
sitting there over them project in
Program Files so if we go back over to
here what if I took one of those
versions I renamed it and then I went
into global Jason
why
what happened
right it found the latest one it did the
best that it could okay so you can pin
that down to that particular version and
it will find that particular thing I've
completely screwed that up now what was
that one not oh that preview three - I
can't control Z an admin thing three one
eight oh that was funny yeah you can't
control Z admin stuff that's why I had
to go dig it out of the the trash there
alright but then if I go out here I get
that I go in here I get that make sense
now we could have just done the easy
thing right and maybe so dotnet was
version and there'd be a bunch of
different ones but then you wouldn't
have Ruby foo Python food foo and I
wouldn't be able to go and take that and
put it on a USB key and give it to you
on a Mac and have you go down to restore
and have it just work all right does
that make sense so you start doing some
really really cool stuff when you do
that exactly so this is a great question
so now John Skeets tries to stress me
out and he says what if what happens to
this project Jason so remember at the
very beginning and thank you by the way
for saying that at the very beginning I
talked about how there's this kind of
coming squishing together of all these
different groups there's 19 different
project types project Jason we all loved
and people liked it because they like
curly braces better than angle brackets
because they're they're curvier and
angle brackets are very scary but the
young people like the curly braces but
it was the features in project done
Jason that people liked but it turns out
that we had asp.net 5 console app
eschaton at 5:00 class library and that
wasn't going to scale it would mean that
we would have to go to 19 different
project types and then make them support
project Jason we have to make a unity do
it and all the zamarons and all the
tooling for it member I set out tooling
slows
down but msbuild is open-source now and
cross-platform and works everywhere so
then we have to ask ourselves why do we
hate msbuild why do we hate CS projects
what do we love about project JSON and
can we come up with something that gives
us the best of both worlds and that's
what's currently happening so the idea
is that you'll still have a project on
Jason structured looking thing it will
just be called CS project it'll be angle
brackets instead of curly braces you'll
look at the way that your CS proj files
usually look where it's like element and
then another element and then some weird
attributes and it's very hard to merge
and anytime you have any kind of a get
conflict it's a mess we'll take some of
those elements and make them attributes
so that those merge conflicts will
happen on just one line okay suddenly
everyone will be able to go and
reference these things all of the
tooling will just light up and just just
work right but we want to be able to
still have intellisense and being able
to bring new get packages in and all
that kind of stuff so we're trying to
bring those things together in fact
there was a private email that David
Fowler David found
you think that he went and screwed up
for me
you think you changed it why is he even
awake it's like 1:00 in the morning
I'm looking for Kieran who talked to
David about this thing that's how I
search for stuff they spelled keyring
wrong I know there's a lot more vowels
in there I don't know how to spell Irish
names
all right so so they're working on some
ideas here where they list out what do
we care about right globbing is cool
swapping packages with projects
seamlessly transitive restores there's
good stuff that they want to be able to
do those are the things we like about
project Jason I don't want people to go
and say oh I love project on Jason
because curly braces or because it's
just called project agitation that's
stupid there's a project Jason file they
are thinking about they are looking at
what if you could have CS projects that
felt and look see John skeets smiling
that makes me happy
it's a CS proj cinemas build filed that
looks like a project at Jason yeah XML
get over it but by putting includes and
versions and stuff like that all in one
line what's that yeah yeah if you just
you try to make it look nice right did
you get any Australian Pokemon today he
he he really likes Pokemon and I'm
really make gonna make him hurt as much
as possible okay
so the point is that we want to preserve
that goods that good experience okay so
let's do this let's go back over to here
I think we got a couple more minutes
left so I'm going down here let me go up
desktop Oh wrong one dot net new dash T
web so now I've got a web app dot in
that restore
Internet in Australia is so good
Tata net run I'm not gonna run edge
localhost 5000 okay
I haven't even loaded Visual Studio yet
or Visual Studio code I just realized
that that is another kind of a cool
thing about this you know I mean
now some people freak out because their
visual people their visual studio they
paid for visual they want the visual and
visual studio literally everything that
you doubt you doing here if you don't
want to see text files you don't like
the command line you don't have to do
any of this
that's the tooling every single thing
that I'm doing changing project Jason's
messing with this kind of stuff there'll
be a way to do it in a visual way but
what this is about is about choice it's
about using Emacs or vim or notepad or
nothing like I'm doing right now okay so
this right here is running right there
and it's running in kestrel but if I
make a change to that file I'm gonna
have to go back here and then run it
again okay so what I want to do is I'm
going to go open up project Jason again
and then I'm going to go back to the
Internet and I'm gonna go dot dot net
watch oh that was weird
dot net watch which is a tool that I can
add and all I have to do is add this
here to the tools section of my project
Jason so tools are different than
references right to go back over here
find the tools section here's the tools
like razor and things like that I add
the dotnet watcher I go back here and I
say dotnet restore this is restoring
packages and in a second here it should
say if I don't have that tool already
restoring tool restoring packages for
tool net watcher okay and then instead
of saying dotnet run I'm gonna say
dotnet watch
run okay running dotnet there you go so
now it's running and I'll go back over
here do a little of this action so I'm
hitting it refresh and I'm clicking
around over here and stuffs happening on
the other side okay but then I'll go
into notepad let's go into a controller
like home controller so I'm here in a
home controller and I hit about I type
in awesome or I don't know there you go
I hit save and the left hand side just
noticed it and recompiled it and then it
runs again makes sense all right so
that's the kind of experience again I
haven't been in visual studio I haven't
been a visual studio code I haven't been
in Emacs but again do whatever you want
it's all pluggable and being able to
like let's imagine that that's a
checkbox in vs right or it's just
automatic like it is that's the kind of
experience that we want to enable that
runs anywhere now there's a longer more
interesting conversation that we can
have about how to do things like that
cross-platform like NTFS has this
pub/sub model so we're actually getting
notified of that but if you look at the
code for dotnet watch there isn't the
ability to do that on Linux or on Macs
so it's a polling file watcher but the
experience is the same so when you go
and write code that runs anywhere you
have to think about how your stuff is
going to work and if you're going to be
porting code if you're doing system dot
drawing which doesn't exist on a Mac or
Linux or you're doing registry access or
things like that you've got to ask
yourself if that code is going to is
going to port the goal the direction
that we are heading is hopefully one
that looks like this
because portable class libraries pcl
seem like a good idea at the time but
they were flawed in two major ways they
were lowest common denominator and they
required you to say where you needed it
to be portable for ahead of time which
is the exact opposite of what you want
when you want portability you don't know
you want to make it portable just cuz
but you had to go in a checkbox and say
I wanted to work on Silverlight and xbox
and windows and that was not cool
and additionally it was a lowest common
denominator so it was basically simple
datatypes and simple structures and
lists of stuff what we want is a
standard library so that you as C sharp
and F sharp developers don't feel like
oh I got to learn mono now up I gotta
learn net core now only I learned dotnet
full framework now you'll learn the
dotnet standard library just like we
learned the BCL 10-15 years ago and then
the the other frameworks that sit on top
of that are the thing that you learn but
really cool innovation can happen here
and because we've open sourced the
compilers and the languages are moving
forward when new things like string
inference a new c-sharp seven isms or
f-sharp 4.1 isms happen it goes all the
way up and everybody gets that great
experience does that make sense so I
think it's a pretty decent time to be a
developer
let's do five or ten minutes at QA and
see if if this talk was any good you're
either shocked or just bored senseless
over here
it's all about the binding of diversions
so we say you bound your application or
you folded to the global version of a
particular dotnet right I was in that
instance use I was changing the version
of the SDK yes the version of the driver
which is separate from changing the
version of the runtime that I would
change in project Jason so global Jason
is in global Jason so when yeah bound to
particular version what happens if that
fusion doesn't exist for instance in
that particular instance today it would
have picked the newest one so you've
just fall back to yeah well that would
be and that's the kind of thing where
from a community perspective if you
think it out a break if that SDK isn't
available then you should like we should
talk about that as a community and like
have those kind of discussions right now
I tested it it picks the latest one
which is an interesting choice good
question
behind you there on the right um when
you install the.net watch and you up
there in the JSON file yeah yeah now
there are any plans to make that
available in command-line like I'm an
NPM install like an NPM install yeah so
it is available at the command line it
is a dotnet tool if I go out to the
command line right now and I say I don't
know how to type and I say dotnet Fred
you see here it says no executable
matching the command net - Fred a dotnet
tool can be anything that is named a
certain way may be PowerShell it could
be his bash script it could be NPM or
whatever yeah I mean how you had to
install the tool and into a dotnet
restore you up that the Jason fall first
right I updated the adjacent file first
because like you're asking me if I
wanted to do it what's the equivalent of
NPM in my - - gee not I guess it could
be a - that to you or a safe dev or no
like you you it's a right now everything
is is local to the project I said dotnet
restore I could go new get install and
pull it out manually
we know it for exam I mention you do it
an NPM install watch oh can I update the
project Jason via the command line yeah
um
it is the yes it pardon me I understand
now it is the intent that yes you'll be
able to do that so we're not going to do
that in project a Jason because we're
moving to the CS proj but the intent is
that you should if you don't want to you
should never have to open up a text file
and edit something like that
so yes pardon me you would be able to do
some gesture dotnet tool add dotnet
watcher got tools and it would show up
in the CS brunch yes that is the intent
I don't know what the exact specs is for
but those conversations happen in the
public on github sorry for my confusion
good question yeah yeah I like editing
text files but I totally get that you
don't want to have to do that you just
want to be able to run it and have it
get done so moving from the project
Jason fallback to CS proach what
certainly the global look Jason we see C
there'll be some kind of solution fall
cleaner better solution file format cool
yeah no what no one likes you know these
formats and we want to have something
that is and by the way there are
features of msbuild that haven't been
exposed in Visual Studio so think about
for example one of the big changes of
project done Jason was switching from
being include all to exclude some right
so with CS projects it sucks because
every single file has to have a line and
then we have multiple teams and somebody
changes something then it's conflict
right project dutch jason says nope
everything gets added by default and
then you just exclude the stuff you
don't want that's been supported in CS
proj and msbuild anyone has written
custom ms builds for years it's just
that it was never expressed in Visual
Studio so it didn't get seen because
again run times are easy and tooling is
complicated so globbing that exists as
well but again no no tooling for it so
yeah the intent is that SES projects
Mahler if it doesn't include a Bill of
Lading of all the crap that it needs and
instead uses globbing and excludes
instead cool good questions cool
somewhat useful appreciate it it's okay
thank you yeah Easter old dotnet
framework going to die is the old dotnet
favorite corny time no absolutely not
do you know that you can run visit calc
on Windows 10 seriously I have a Mac at
home that is on Snow Leopard because it
was on a certain processor type and then
one day Apple just said no and it's been
stuck there as like a bug in amber just
frozen like Jurassic Park for the last
10 years it runs just fine but it can
never ever move forward
Microsoft is really really good backward
compatibility Hedlund didn't work well
will file a bug immediately does Evelyn
even exist anymore
can we go in gw-basic does that well
we'll get I want to get on those things
right away we'll make yeah we'll get
that handled no but seriously though no
the.net framework the full framework
continues if you take a look just at
four point six point two it wasn't just
a series of bug fixes it was a lot of
stuff dotnet four point six point two
blog this was just two days ago we had
updates to click once we had updates to
high DPI and having individual monitor
dpi stuff for WPF so you know work
continues additionally remember that
dotnet core is a server-side thing right
if you're going to be doing stuff at WPF
or wind forms which still there are
millions and millions of projects being
done for them you're gonna be using
dotnet framework and it's worth pointing
out that Roslyn underlies all of this
stuff
so when Roslyn gets better dotnet full
framework gets better when F sharp gets
better everything gets better so yeah I
would say that it might slow down but
it's not dead no and if it even if it
was it'd still be supported for 20 years
as a question over there we still
support BB six that's true that must
make you happy
we are one over here yes so we
understand that dotnet core has been
here for more than 15 years and dotnet
Darnell is done in FEMA yeah yeah sure
and then dotnet core which is actually a
cross-platform will be running only you
know the Mac or Linux so does it mean
that dotnet core which is running on
Linux will not have all the capability
of dotnet framework that we have now
yeah but is there any in near future of
our future is there possibility that
that dotnet code will have the all that
capability that dotnet Remo no okay so
the gentleman is asking the question
about what core is it's been core means
to like pare something down to its
essence dotnet core has less stuff less
surface area less methods available
you're never going to see W Windows PF
on Linux right so can i you're not going
to see WPF for dotnet core running on
Linux it just doesn't make any sense
WinForms windows forms not going to go
to Linux but as far as surface area of
the base class libraries I think that
you're going to see those kinds of
libraries get raised up but you're also
going to see dotnet standard libraries
that make functionality available in
both places those dotnet standard
libraries will work in dotnet core and
on full framework will you be able to do
the exact same stuff it depends on what
people ask for but remember that the
focus is server-side cloud density those
are the things that dotnet core is meant
for the full framework is meant for you
know what it does today
so we were just saying it don't it call
for server-side stuff but also for IOT
yeah and mobile yeah it's sort of the
bottom and the top yeah John skeet makes
a really good important point that
don''t core didn't just pop out of
nowhere right there there's there's a
there's some historical stuff where it
came from some of the the CLR work that
was done in Windows Phone and in
Silverlight to make a a tiny CLR so it
is it is a parallel fork that has many
many years of history in it to be an
optimized modern version of the CLR
modernized jitter modernized GC and it
runs again on a Raspberry Pi yeah
couple more couple more questions when
the don't need framework team or
developers do their work and they want
to add a new feature to donut framework
do they have to actually code it twice
now one for the actual framework and one
for call no so you can make a library
that works in both places you can code
it once you can make a new get package
that can do cross compilation so like
for example if I added Jason net which
is like the canonical canonical example
everyone uses that nougat package is one
thing it's Newton soft Jason but if you
look in it there are versions of that to
run anywhere and the new get or Visual
Studio will automatically do the right
thing and say oh I see you're writing a
uwp app for Xbox or oh I see you're
doing this in xamarin on unity or mono
on unity and it he wrote the code once
he may have some if deaths to keep track
of whether he's running on this version
of that version but no you don't have to
write the code multiple times you may
have to test it multiple times but you
don't write it multiple times
what about the bco developers about you
doing double the work now well so the
BCL when we think the bcl the base class
library that's done it full frame work
and that's having small additions
incremental additions like we just saw
in four point six point two core FX
which are those broken apart like then
it's almost like the BCL as expressed in
a series of nougat packages and then
this surface area of the dotnet standard
library if we add a bunch of stuff to
that we're gonna version that and
they'll be dotnet standard library 2.0
and 2.1 and things like that i didn't
get a lot of time to talk about the
dotnet standard library but yeah if they
weren't familiar with how android does
API levels right there's like 68 million
versions of android but you don't think
about that when you're developing or you
try not to you say I want API level 15
and I know it will run on these things
the same thing will apply with dotnet
standard you'll say I want dotnet core
app 1.0 which is a meta package of
packages and that implements or allows
me to implement rather don''t standard
1.5
and right now we're working on on 2.0
for later that will include more stuff
so that bigger and bigger surface area
means that more and more devices get
more and more functions that's going to
be like an API level and then when you
pick one if you want to make things run
anywhere like Windows 7 you might have
to go back in time and say I want dotnet
standard library 1.2 so that I might
support Windows XP or Windows 7 or
whatever okay
if you want to learn about dotnet
standard library and all that kind of
stuff there is a really good document
right there where he talks about it I
think we're out of time
cool all right thanks y'all